the Native American tribe living on the
us-mexico border fears that building a
wall would threaten its future a new
cbsn original documentary called the the
wall a nation divided explores life on
the border
Mireya Villarreal traveled to the Tohono
o odham reservation in Arizona she gives
us a revealing look at the land which
has become a prime corridor for drugs
and migrants trying to enter the u.s.
this is crazy
so where is Mexico right past that
baggage right there and you you're
comfortable going back and forth no
problem huh I have no problem so I'm
actually in Mexico right now you're in
Mexico yeah in the US right now that's
what the boundary is the federal
government recognized stripes has solver
nieces we're not going over yeah we
shall remain here that's where the
creator put us that's where you go with
it just outside Tucson Arizona the
beautiful landscape of the Sonoran
Desert has become a prime target
desperate migrants and criminal
smugglers funnel onto the Tohono o odham
z-- sacred and sovereign land where
there is no concrete wall instead Border
Patrol agents rely on vehicle barriers a
crumbling fence and constant patrols to
keep illegal activity at bay oh there's
a group see there there's four or five
right here in this group on this
mountain ridge and then there's four
silhouetted there's there's three of you
see if the report Ogden and then there's
like three or four right here yep I
don't understand why are they just
sitting there because they're scouting
us right now the Tohono o odham tribe is
also fighting against the traffickers
and the feds trying to chase them down
tribal members like David Garcia are
willing to risk everything to stop
construction of a border wall on their
land if this wall is built they will
destroy everything that we've lived and
held on all these years the question was
asked
me what are you willing to do I have
already made up my mind if it means
losing my life then that's what it means
but I joins us at the table good morning
good morning thanks for having me so
what would happen if a wall were
actually built you know I think it's you
have to realize that these people don't
have or keep history the way we do they
don't have the history books or the
history classes so for them it's all
about being able to visit family speak
their language share their stories and
if a border wall is put on the border
there in Tucson or near Tucson they
disconnect from the people there their
tribes member in Mexico and so they feel
like their heritage and their history is
at stake for them right now are they
doing anything to try to prevent the
wall in seconds you know I think I think
they are trying to work with the federal
government but they are getting their
legal team together and they're they're
also notifying other tribes around the
country thanks the wall divided
premieres tonight at 8:00 on CBS NR 27
digital network